foreign
do you want to get married and if you do
do you think that your wife material
I'm like I'm gonna get someone else
do you think your wife material
no I don't think I'm wifey materials now
like I'm not wifey material at all like
with cooking and stuff like because I
live with my parents
so like someone my mother is like the
the person who's in charge of the whole
household you they she cooks and
everything so I don't think I'd be
materialistic wife now maybe in the
future yeah are you are you trying to
learn to be aware I think in the future
I would definitely try to learn but for
now I'm just like YOLO no I don't really
care about like
I cannot I can't even crack an egg girl
but I don't care I at least I can
[ __ ]
now I'm just like YOLO because I'm not
gonna get married I've got a lot of
years to catch up but yeah I've got a
lot of years too yeah ladies okay you're
18. do you think you're worth material
do you think you're worth material so I
think I'm my material uh I do think I'm
white material but I also think that
that's gonna that's quite subjective so
I think men might find white material to
different men is going to be different
things they might look for different
things in a wife do you know what I mean
but if you you're asking me if I'm wife
material I'd say yeah I think what do
you think makes you working with you
um so I think a lot of those like
feminine attributes that we spoke about
earlier so being nurturing and being
caring
um allowing yourself to be led by the
right man
um yeah and I you know I want to take
care of my man I want to take care of my
home I want to take care of my family
those are all things that I want to do
and I think those are all things that
you know you can fall under being good
wife materials on the video the Filipina
P shout out to the Filipina P looks like
that's going to be my wife
I'm not into Filipino women but it's
just you know whatever
um she understands what it is or the
women generally in those countries it
seems that they generally understand
what it is that men want in a wife okay
right
um
do you think you can compete
with women like that
yeah yeah yeah okay uh yes you don't
know me though so how can you say that
no I don't yeah no I wasn't talking I
was talking
you haven't seen me anymore you have
kids don't you yeah yeah how many just
two how would you compete with a single
childless woman is she single and
childless Filipino yeah yeah yeah okay
well it
material in the aspects of being fit in
your feminine and you're talking about
just Purity if that is the only standard
that we're talking about then obviously
knocks and can't yeah so I can't compete
with Purity no you know you know how
women like the the top 20 over six foot
x amount of money do you know the top 20
for men if they had the choice and the
option to do do you know what those that
that category of women will be no
children it'll be a single virgin woman
that's pretty much the top one or two
percent I'm not struggling but what I
mean is I know no no no I'm sure you'll
be fine there's the simps everywhere but
yeah of course of course but what I mean
is that that is the top 20 for men is
that single attractive thin woman that's
what we're all aiming for now some of us
fall uh you know basically we settle uh
for simping or whatever else but I
promise you that as much as if you go
with a five foot six or five foot eight
man who's earning forty thousand pounds
a year and you're settling for if a man
is going with a woman who's had two
children he is settling yeah but that's
okay
it's really difficult to find like I
think it would be difficult to find
someone when you've got two kids and
you're a single mother I mean
think of it from the guy's perspective
foreign
he says Mama found a girl oh really son
you found a girl yeah who is she this
girl she's got two kids
all right let's say even if your son's
let's say your son is 40 now okay well
if he's 40 then if he loves him
it's not mine it's not mine wait wait
because didn't he behind us say that
there's different pools right no but I'm
sorry if your son's wife your son's 40.
you would think his first choice should
be someone with kids well what if he had
bipart
so what's wrong with him why doesn't he
even if he even if he does even even
okay even if he had kids why would he
pick a woman with kids over a woman
without like this [ __ ] is if she doesn't
have children if she doesn't have
children she may not have a level of
understanding that he might need for him
having his children over in the house
and all of these different elements that
go into having a child even if you're a
man if you're looking after if you're
co-parenting you're going to have them
children on your own if you've got a
woman that's going to want your
undivided attention and you're not able
to give it that might give it he don't
understand men like when you say that I
hear it because you're speaking from a
woman's perspective well I can only do
that yeah of course but you don't but as
a man and as men here we know that if
we're gonna pick a woman for our
long-term part
we're not trying to find some single
moment yeah I mean Sarah you you have a
son I have a son and I understand that a
lot of women would negate me because I
haven't because I have a son yeah
because I've probably got caught in
court baggage that I could be bringing
with me right so I understand your mama
drama baby mama drama whatever it is
right and I understand that but yeah and
I understand that I'm not every woman's
first choice
a lot of the time
single mothers don't understand they're
not men's first choice I understand that
but I also think like you're kind of but
you guys somebody that I used to date
but you've literally said to me but you
guys aren't answering like even when I
ask you a simple question like I'll say
okay if he's 40 and he who should his
first choice be you guys will still not
give it to you no answer no no
what if he is
I gave you my genuine answer just
because it is no I don't I just think
it's not honest well that is my honest I
wouldn't say I've been honest in every
other element if my son was 40 and he
met somebody who he truly loved and was
and had children and she had and she had
children that should be his first choice
yeah
as his mother it's not my job to tell
him what to do at 40 years old
because he raised this man yeah
yeah and him he should be able to make I
if I haven't done my job good enough
today at 40 years old that he can't make
a decision decision on his own he needs
to come to Mummy to ask him
as well can I just interject with a more
realistic scenario which in fact
every day
at the back but sign language but as far
as a real situation which actually I
know someone who exactly in this
position they were 27 28 with a
brilliant business really successful
already had two houses uh married a
woman a single mother at 37. would you
allow yourself
the person I know was 20 yeah
single mother but how am I allowing
right you're saying allowing as if I
have control no no but what I mean is
would you be happy with that yeah yeah I
want her to come home with with her kids
are you gonna want her to uh are you
going to tell your son yeah bring go on
bring the girl home are you gonna 100
100 if my son is happy and he comes home
to me and say mum this is the woman that
I love and I am going to marry her and
these are 100 who am I to tell him oh
yeah right I do agree and I'm very I'm
very nurturing
femininity isn't cutting me off so it's
like as you as his mother your opinion
matters right and so it's like you could
say oh son I don't think that's maybe a
good idea or you would say it's a good
idea
why would he come home and ask for my
opinion
I mean
in a relationship do you go home and
actually I I I'll say this when I got
with I was in a previous relationship
for 10 years right and I got with a
single mother and when I never had any
children right and I I specifically
remember my mom saying
I don't know son this might not be the
one but I know you say you love her but
I don't know and the thing is my mom
turned out to be right
but also right because my mom as a woman
of age who's already had her children
she could foresee the future that I
couldn't see I'm in love Mama love this
woman yeah I'm great she's thinking uh
down the road son there was no red pill
there was no manosphere to help me out
when I was in that situation I just had
my mum and I didn't listen to her do I
wish that I would have hell [ __ ] yeah
because my mom had a had an insight and
a wisdom that I didn't have so as a
mother you have an insight and a wisdom
that your son doesn't have so what so
when your son comes to you
in his 20s or whatever and says Mama
found a woman and you know she's got
children and you are you literally gonna
be like yeah yes and that's the one oh
you're gonna be like
yeah come on
yeah
and I think there's a difference between
sitting your son down and being like son
you haven't got kids yet she's got kids
are you sure about this do you
understand them are you really looking
yeah with this are you ready for this I
think there's a difference between
having that conversation and being like
Oh my God no no no this is wrong you
should go you said you're what 37 two
children
would you let if you because you know
yourself yeah would you let your son
Choose You
um a woman just like you two children 37
and he's in his would you let your son
choose someone just like I would
probably say no because I just wouldn't
want to put that pressure on someone
that's 27 right for me I just wouldn't
feel comfortable being with someone at
27 and I'm just saying I've got this
comes with a lot of responsibility we're
probably different life stages you know
what I'm saying so for me it's probably
going to be a no and that's what I'm
saying I would have that conversation
with my son but ultimately it's his
decision
of course yeah so I would have that
conversation you've given some advice
yeah I've given some advice and like you
said there's that foresight that insight
there yeah because you've got it right
exactly but I just think if he doesn't
have kids like it doesn't matter how
nice she is like I would tell him to not
deal with her because she's got kids
I would say just like yeah like and it's
just it's not personal it's just like
that's a lot of that's a lot of
responsibility yeah exactly and you
didn't make that decision and you're
going to be the one responsible for it
I'm gonna I'm gonna be a little bit
crude but um yeah I mean the person that
I that I'm talking about they eventually
got divorced and uh they did he does
have a daughter from from that marriage
but um generally I saw it coming and my
advice was straight up pumping up as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible